et puis enfin air france poursuite de la
grève des mécaniciens au sol qui se sont
regroupés dans une coordination sept
vols ont été annulés aujourd'hui ont été
ou seront au portage anthony une cadence
et un rythme auquel on ne s'attend pas
quand on pénètre dans un atelier d'air
france si ce que provoque la vue d'une
caméra chez ses mécaniciens au sol ils
sont en grève maintenant depuis plus de
trois semaines une heure par jour pour
1500 fond d'augmentation par mois et
plus d'effectifs la direction emploi de
plus en plus de malheurs intérimaire bon
cette manne aux intérimaires et
non-qualifié pour travailler sur avions
donc sont les mécaniciens qui sont
obligés de leur montrer comment
effectuer ce travail
en plus de cela bon il bien sûr il faut
qu'ils fassent leur travail à eux
puisque c'est là c'est lors de ces la
visite normale
ensuite on est obligé de contrôler le
travail effectué par ces personnes qui
sont qualifiés ce qui entraîne un
surcoût de travail très important et
d'où un risque à terme de remise en
cause de la sécurité
la direction d'air france qui ne
souhaite pas s'exprimer sur ce conflit
conteste ces propos de plus elle fait
savoir qu'elle a mis en place un plan de
recrutement immédiat de 250 personnes
pour les salaires air france répond que
2 % d'augmentation déjà été accordée
cette année
enfin son effort d'investissement la
commande de 60 appareils sur dix ans ne
lui permettent pas dit elle de prendre
en compte l'ensemble des revendications
des mécaniciens au sol